so before we get started with the review
here I want to say thank you a heartfelt
thank you because I've been on YouTube
for 10 years that looks like 10 years in
two days it was 10 years on the night
but thank you for that thank you for
allowing me to be on here accepting me
on here thank you to people who we're
like yeah I'll listen to this guy I
guess I'll listen to the next video and
if you just pass through a couple times
thank you if you came by and you were
like [ __ ] this hassle thank you if you
came by and stuck around thank you I
kind of want to make a video about it
but I don't know how I would approach I
don't know what I would do rather than
say thank you so I'm just gonna say
thank you here and if and when I figure
it out and that's an IFO I'll make a
video about it until then legit you
changed my life for the better so thank
you
[Music]
so crawl it here's the premise of crawl
a hurricane rolls through this small
town this girl can't get a hold of her
dad her dad's going to be thin like
ground zero of the Hurricanes she goes
it is blaze his place is sequential he
flooding and that's right
he's in the basement or the cross crawl
I just got that pretty big crawlspace so
much so I call it a basement point is
there are alligators down there and they
got to survive it and escape them and
try to go around them and try to got
outsmart the alligators yeah it sounds
like cheese it sounds like it was gonna
be hot [ __ ] garbage I was like
sharknado
but with alligators and a hurricane so
hurricane Gator her a gator her querque
whatever I'm done trying to make a word
for it I'm watching it I'm like this is
bafflingly good it's like way better
than it ever had a right to bait first
of all our protagonist our hero here
she's great she carries the movie she's
the heart of the movie you could say her
and Barry Pepper Barry Pepper plays her
dad you could say it's their dynamic
when the movie first comes on you see
her swimming and I was like this is way
more character development than a movie
like this would have so I thought and
bring on the disaster movie with Gators
and the cast list is pretty short that's
all I really gotta address is her in him
but it was really intense to like you
know she gets out of this crawl space
these alligators kept like look I'm not
a gator expert I don't even know the
difference between an alligator and a
crocodile I look at these they look like
crocodiles to me I guess they're
alligators I can't stop to care too much
because I'm enjoying the disaster movie
I was just baffled and how often in this
movie I'm like oh come on I thought it
would just be laughing in this movie I
went to this movie straight up looking
for a comedy when I learned there was
one other human being one other
life-form in this auditorium other than
myself all those having fun but now well
it tells me as people aren't really
going to see this movie and that means a
lot of people are missing out on a
pretty enjoyable thriller I like movies
that just take place in one
claustrophobic space and there's a big
problem and they just they got to solve
it and throughout the movie they're just
hurdles getting thrown at them I mean by
hurdles I mean hurdles these two are ice
skating uphill it's like for every step
they take forward they get knocked two
steps back I do call [ __ ] I'm not
gonna say don't call [ __ ] I'm not
just talking about I don't know the
difference between alligator
how they act I'm saying I call [ __ ]
and a couple times
some people all right she takes some
damage but she doesn't really take
damage I'll address one that happens
very early on in the movie so it's not
like well that was in the third act no
it's in the first - she thinks she might
find a way she's doing the thing
alligator grabs her leg and just
thrashing the [ __ ] out of her very next
scene she's running on that same leg no
compound fracture I guess it's not that
bad running on the what do you even have
the fact that she has a leg that baffles
makes like well if you have two people
that are severely wounded now they're
just bait they can't get out of the
house you need one who's very able body
but you also need that one to receive a
thrashing or two otherwise it doesn't
feel too intense they just feel
invincible so I get it I just above
saying a couple times I'm like you have
a limb that's unexpected as in the end
crawl it was very surprising it was a
legette very effective claustrophobic
monster movie with alligators not
monsters couple of times I call [ __ ]
a couple of times you roll your eyes all
right Hollywood it doesn't change the
fact that I walked out of this movie
having had a good time no alcohol
required
alright so crawl have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's a
thriller that you enjoyed that surprise
the holiday you're going into this thing
going alright there's gonna be a hot
garbage and you walk out going Wow
okay it entertained me whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you'd like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]